Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
We've been talking
about Taylor series
for a number of
functions and rules
by which you can
compute Taylor series.
I have here an example that I
don't think we did in lecture.
So this is the function f
of x equals secant of x.
Now, unlike some of the
other ones you've seen,
there's not a really simple
formula for the whole Taylor
series of secant x.
So what I'd like you
to do is not to find,
you know, a formula
for the general term,
but rather, just to
use some of the tools
that we've learned to
compute the first few terms
of the Taylor series for
f of x equals secant x.
Say, up through the x to the
fourth term, if you wanted,
or even a little further if
you were feeling ambitious.
So why don't you pause the
video, have a go at that,
come back, and we
can do it together.
So welcome back.
I asked you to compute the first
few terms of a Taylor series.
One thing you can always do
in this case, is you can go
and you can apply the
general formula that we
have for Taylor
series, and use it
to compute the series that way.
So in order to do
that, you just need
to compute a few derivatives
of your function.
So remember that the general
formula for a Taylor series
is the Taylor series for f of
x is equal to the sum from n
equals 0 to infinity
of the nth derivative
of f taken at zero divided by
n factorial times x to the n.
And since we're only interested
in the first few terms,
this is f of 0
plus f prime of 0 x
plus f double prime of 0 over
2 x squared, plus dot dot dot.
I'm not going to write
out the next few terms.
And if you want to apply
this formula to secant
of x, what you
would have to do, is
you would have to compute
these derivatives.
And so we could try doing that.
So in our case, f of x
is equal to secant of x.
So f of 0 is secant
of 0, which is just 1.
So then we need to know
f prime of x, so that's
the derivative of secant of x.
So this is one you
should remember.
This is equal to
secant x times tan x.
And when you plug in x equal
to 0, well, the tan x is 0.
So f prime of 0 is equal to 0.
And then you could keep going.
So you could compute
f double prime of x.
So we would have to compute the
derivative of secant x tan x.
And you would do that
by the product rule.
You know, you take
derivative of secant
of x, and that gives you
secant x tan x times tan
x plus-- and then you, OK.
So you leave secant of
x, and you multiply it
by the derivative of tangent,
which is secant squared x.
And now when you put in 0 here,
you get f double prime of 0.
Well, OK.
So this has a tan x
in it, so that part's
going to give you 0.
And here we end up with secant
of 0 times secant squared of 0,
so that's 1 times 1 times 1.
So that's just 1.
So f double prime of 0 is 1,
and you could keep doing this.
Now one thing you'll notice
is that this is getting
more and more complicated.
I mean, we can simplify this
expression a little bit.
We could write it as
secant x tan squared
x plus secant cubed x,
and there are, you know,
all sorts of trig
manipulations you could do,
if you wanted to try and rewrite
that in some simpler form.
But fundamentally,
it's more complicated
than the first derivative
was, and that's
more complicated
in the function.
And it will keep getting
more complicated as you
compute more derivatives.
So we can do this.
So so far this shows us, by the
way, that this is equal to 1
plus 0x plus x squared
over 2 plus dot dot dot.
And if you wanted
to compute, you
know, up through the fourth
degree term or something
like this, that's something
that's manageable.
But I want to suggest that
there are maybe some nicer ways
to do it.
So one thing to notice
is that secant of x
is closely related to
the function cosine of x.
And you know the Taylor
series for cosine of x.
So one thing you
could think to do,
is to leverage the information
that you have about cosine
of x in order to use it to get
some information about secant
of x.
So one simple way to do that, is
that you know that cosine of x
is even.
It's an even function.
Cosine of minus x is
equal to cosine of x.
So that means secant
of x is also even.
Secant of x is an even function.
And you've seen that even
functions, their Taylor
series, all the odd
powers have coefficient 0.
So what that means is
without ever computing
the third derivative,
we can know already
that the next term
in this Taylor series
is going to be 0 x cubed over 6.
OK?
So that's nice.
So the odd terms of the Taylor
series for secant of x are 0.
OK.
So that's one thing
you can get right away.
So that gives you,
if you like, that
gives you half of the
terms of the Taylor series.
It's a little bit
of a joke, but.
OK, so then you only need to
figure out the even terms.
That's one way we can leverage
the relationship between secant
and cosine.
The other way is
that we can remember
that Taylor series multiply
just like polynomials do.
So if secant is 1
over cosine, that
means secant times
cosine is equal to 1.
OK?
So idea, secant of x times
cosine of x is equal to 1.
Now, that means that
the Taylor series
for secant of x times the
Taylor series for cosine of x
has to simplify just to 1.
So we can write
down that product
as a product of two
infinite polynomials,
and we can start
multiplying term by term.
And that'll allow us to
solve for a bunch of terms,
just by solving some
simple linear equations.
So let me show you what I mean.
So we know-- let me write
it as cosine times secant.
So we know that cosine of x is
1 minus x squared over 2 plus x
to the fourth over 24--
that's 4 factorial-- minus x
to the sixth over 720, which is
6 factorial, plus dot dot dot.
And so we know that
if we multiply this
by the series for
secant of x-- well,
what is the series
for secant of x?
Well, we've already
computed a few terms.
We know that it's 1
plus x squared over 2,
we computed that already.
And we know that the
third degree term is 0.
So there's some fourth
degree coefficient, a_4, x
to the fourth, or 4 factorial.
And there's some-- well,
we know, we said it's even,
so we know the fifth
degree coefficient is 0.
So then the sixth degree
coefficient we don't know yet.
So this is plus a sub 6 times x
to the sixth over 6 factorial,
plus dot dot dot.
So we know that when we multiply
these two things together,
it has to give us just 1.
All the higher-order
terms have to cancel,
because over here we have a 1.
So what you can do, is
you can actually try
multiplying these things out.
So it's easy to
see, for example,
that the constant term of this
product is just 1 times 1,
which is 1.
Which is good.
So that's a check on
what we've done so far.
And there is no x-term,
because there are no x's.
The x squared term
here is 1 times
x squared over 2 minus x
squared over 2 times 1.
Well, that gives us
0, so that's good.
So this product is
equal to-- well, it's 1,
plus we saw 0x,
plus 0 x squared.
How about the x cubed term?
Well, there are no odd
terms in this product,
so there's no x cubed.
How about the x to
the fourth term?
Well, OK.
So how do we get
an x to the fourth?
We could have an x to the
fourth here times a constant.
So that's x to the
fourth over 24.
Or, we could have an x
squared times an x squared.
So in this case, that gives us
minus x squared over 2 times
x squared over 2, which is
minus x to the fourth over 4.
Or we could have a constant
times an x to the fourth.
So this is plus a_4 x
to the fourth over 24.
And then we'll have a
sixth-degree term, and so on.
Notice that there's
never any involvement
from the higher-order terms
in the fourth power here.
Right?
If you ever took an
x to the sixth here,
well then everything you
multiply it by has at least an
x to the sixth power.
So we don't have to worry
about that showing up
in the x to the fourth term.
Well, OK.
We know this is
actually equal to 1,
so we know that this
thing has to be 0.
This is x to the fourth term.
It has to be 0.
So that means that 1 over 24
minus 1 over 4 plus a_4 over 24
equals 0.
So OK.
So now you can multiply
everything through by 24
and rearrange to figure
out that a_4 is equal to 5.
So I've done that correctly.
And then if you wanted, it would
be fairly easy to go back up
and then you look at
the x to the sixth term.
And from there, you
could figure out
that a_6 was equal to, say,
61 or something like that.
I think 61.
And you could keep doing this.
So this is one way
to compute more terms
of the series for secant of x.
Another thing you could
do-- which I'll just
mention very briefly,
I'm not going to show you
how to do it-- is that
you can do long division
on power series.
So it actually works out very--
it works out just like this.
It's mathematically equivalent.
The way you actually
do it looks different.
It looks like long division.
When you do long division
with polynomials,
you start with the
highest-order term.
Of course, power series don't
have highest-order terms.
What you actually do
with a power series, is
you start with the
lowest-order term.
So to divide this
into 1, you'd say, oh,
you need a factor of
1, and then you'll
have a-- you know, you
subtract off 1 times this,
and that gives you
an x squared plus 2.
And so, OK, so you say, I need
a plus an x squared plus 2,
and so on.
So that was too brief for you
to understand it properly,
but you can go and look
up somewhere the method
of long division
on power series.
So just to recap, we
talked about three methods
for computing the coefficients
of a power series.
There's the formula that
you were given, which works,
and which you could use.
In this case, it's a
little complicated.
Then there's the method
of using a relationship
between your power series
and other known power series.
In this case, we can
use the relationship
that we know our power series
satisfies a certain product.
We know that our power series
times cosine of x equals to 1,
and we can use that to solve
for some of the coefficients.
Or you can also, similarly,
when you have that situation,
you can also use long division
to compute the coefficients.
I'll end there.